RANI PARUCHURI: Hi,
I am Rani Paruchuri,
and this is my first
ever talk on camera.
Thanks to Google for
this opportunity.
I am not an engineer, but
architected software products.
I am not a trained
insurance professional,
but designed insurance systems.
I had never been to business
school, but, as a CEO,
I am running my
own company, which
I started eight years back.
These are, in short,
my achievements.
How did I get here?
Let me tell you my
long story in short.
My determination to
achieve something
had started by seeing
my uneducated mother go
through hardships due to the
sudden death of my father
when I was 11 years old.
My education was
supported by my uncle,
who admitted me in computer
science education in 1989.
My love towards
computers started
when I saw output of my first
basic language program, which
was addition of two numbers.
In fact, I copied the
program from my friend.
At the age of 22, as a married
woman and a mother of a child,
I started my first business for
desktop publishing, [INAUDIBLE]
Computers, in my living room.
My first owned
computer was 80286,
whose speed is I can start the
system, clean my [INAUDIBLE]
and come back, it
would have booted up.
I started my
business, but did not
have the required
skills for designing.
I taught myself tools
like Pagemaker, CorelDraw,
to design brochures, business
cards, books, et cetera.
Learning any new technology
those days was a humongous
effort, only available sources
were books and help manuals.
Unlike now, where we are
flooded with thousands
of videos, forums, even
with source code directly.
I expanded my business from
DTP into IT training and taught
hundreds of students and
professionals in various
technologies, like COBOL,
Pascal, C, C++, Java, SQL,
PeopleSoft, SCAP, and
the list continued.
At the age of 33, I left
my secure job with Intel
to pursue my dream of building a
product-based software company,
and started Dream Tekis
software with my brother
and other partners.
I built my first product
with great passion
by putting all my
experience in place,
but failed miserably
in marketing
it, as I depended on a
partner company for marketing.
The future became uncertain,
but I never gave up,
waited for the
opportunity, came to know
that there is a need for
a good insurance system.
But I was totally new
to insurance, other
than having a couple of policies
and paying the premiums only
due to the force of an agent.
All the while, I taught
myself technologies,
but for the first time, I
taught myself insurance domain
and designed world class life
insurance product, Soham Life.
This time, I did not take
a chance with marketing.
I traveled across the globe
and marketed my products.
I was told by our
local partners they
had never come across a
woman tech CEO traveling
to Africa for business.
Probably, I was the first one.
In past eight years,
every Dream Tekis employee
have shared the same dream as
ours, and built Soham products.
Today, Dream Tekis is trading
with international clients
from seven different countries
whose insurance business runs
on Soham systems.
I'm proud and privileged
to build products
with the tag of "Made in India."
My dreams and
aspirations continue.
So what got me here
is sheer determination
to achieve something in life.
I would like to take
this opportunity
to tell all the women
out there, if you
are determined to achieve,
nothing can stop you.
Neither marriage, nor
technology, or circumstances.
Turn every adversity
into an opportunity,
and never give up
until you succeed.
Keep going.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]